I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense we went to Amsterdam one day I'm
just wind Amsterdam did you go to the
coffee shops yeah we had no idea what
we're doing
did you eat brownies yeah so funny to
talk to you about this well the funny
part was the funniest story was is one
of our best friends he's a Army Ranger
mm-hmm
and he's never drank or smoked ever ever
he's just straight-laced so we're in
Amsterdam and I had two brownies I was
eating he wanted to try one so I gave
him a little brownie because these
aren't bad and I said you know they got
powder in me goes I don't feel anything
any ate the whole brownie how much are
you supposed to eat just a few bites
like a quarter of I hate the whole
brownie so he was fried and it's never
been that way in his life so we go that
we end up going to this we were in
Amsterdam went to a coffee went to our
actual coffee shop which was Starbucks
and he tried order and tai chi latte
yeah he couldn't say that if he had to
not always good exactly imagine saying
after eating a full brownie oh man
that's funny that's really funny
Wow his mom have one too she had a
couple nipples I never seen her she ate
some brownie just you don't turn into a
different person
you don't know he'll start jumping
around jumping off roofs and laying on
the ground and doing the worm and stuff
like that you just chill out
you